[Music]
hey guys we are so excited to announce
we are producing our own original
content head over to the trendy for the
best DIYs fashion tips makeup acts and
so much more we are sure you're going to
love it and be sure to let us know what
you think in the comment section we love
to hear from you there a lot of Disney
Princesses are very good role models for
children they stand up for what they
believe in
they're compassionate and some of them
refuse to take no for an answer but what
they still act this way in today's world
stick around to see them reimagined with
tattoos and piercings hola
did you hear about our latest addition
to our family their richest espanol is
the perfect place for all you native
Spanish speakers out there don't speak
Spanish no problem come on over this is
the perfect place to practice amazing
facts interesting people and funny
pictures those hemos ahi let's check out
ten Disney Princesses reimagined as
modern-day women Ariel The Little
Mermaid is still one of the most popular
Disney stories out there everyone loves
Ariel's long red hair and if we were to
see a modern version of the Disney
mermaid her hair would be one of the
main features we found a bunch of
talented artists who made awesome
creations and showed us what Ariel would
look like in the modern world check
these out
this incredibly realistic drawing that
kind of reminds us of Lindsay Lohan
belongs to Fernanda Suarez who is known
for her incredibly realistic
illustrations isn't this version just
totally gorgeous here's another one this
one belongs to Fox Ville from tumblr who
even kept a symbolic fork in Ariel's
hair
Milo Jade from deviantART turned Ariel
into a singer and we are in love with
her sparkly dress we all know Ariel has
a beautiful voice but what a modern-day
Ariel used the same voice rinrin Daichi
from deviantART took it to the next
level with this incredible illustration
this modern areal features tattoos and
piercings her fiery red hair definitely
goes well with her Punk look what do you
think the modern-day Little Mermaid
would look like would she be a hipster a
punk rocker a singer or just a regular
office girl and let's not forget about
the ultimate modern-day Ariel
Alyssa Milano after all she inspired the
mermaids look Rapunzel
her long blonde hair and her cheery
personality would make Rapunzel a
perfect modern-day character
she's definitely a popular Disney
Princess but these artists really
managed to bring out her best features
and reimagine her as a modern-day woman
we can't even pick our favorite ones
lenzi Ella the talented tumblr artist
showed two separate versions of Rapunzel
in the modern world
so first chose the long-haired princess
in a miniskirt and a denim jacket but
the second version brings her to life
she looks like a normal person
Keele young from deviantART also gave us
two different versions first we have a
Christmas Rapunzel who looks like she's
filming one of those Christmas haul
YouTube videos and the second version
shows Rapunzel in a very casual outfit
we bet this version of the tangled
princess is actually a popular youtuber
with a makeup and hairstyling channel a
mere our showed Rapunzel with an
attitude the punk-rock look would
definitely suit the blonde princess
considering she's quite a rebellious
character and lastly Maya oh 211 from
deviantART also put her in a modern
world and created this gorgeous shot
doesn't the long blonde hair remind you
of Blake Lively come to think of it
Blake really is the real-life modern-day
Rapunzel we're sure Rapunzel would do
just fine in the modern world and we
better hair would change color and
length more often than it should anna
and elsa comment below if you still love
to sing let it go the snow glows white
on the mountain tonight not a footprint
to be seen
admit it how long did it take for you to
get let it go out of your head we bet
you haven't forgotten about honor and
Elsa the fans of frozen turned out to be
some of the most amazing artists ever
and we managed to find some really cool
illustrations of the two sisters in the
modern world the first to belong to puns
v Ella who first illustrated Anna and
Elsa as cartoons but then brought them
to life their fashions totally looks
like something they'd actually wear in
today's world and we're in love with
both of their hairstyles Lina Deluxe
from deviantART showed us a very
fashionable Elsa who seems to be dressed
to impress her long blonde hair is still
there but it's the clothes that make her
totally modern speaking of clothes
check out this version by dr. pepper
Dwight from deviantART on an Elsa might
just be
the cutest in their Christmas sweaters
but they're still fashionable with a
long black boot and if that's FEM the
deer on their sweaters but the award for
the best modern-day version of the two
sisters belongs to the editing Disney
Instagram account
they turned Anna and Elsa into Ariana
Grande and Nicki Minaj and their looks
are absolutely amazing these two sisters
from arendelle would definitely fit
right in
Mulan's let's get down to business to
defeat the Huns how could you not love
everything about Milan this Disney
princess shares an important message
that's definitely still relevant in
today's world check her out as a modern
day woman
Fernanda Suarez gave her a totally
realistic illustration and were in love
with the detail of her ear piercings and
jewelry it definitely portrays Milan
very well but it gets even better
Tashia MS from Instagram illustrated
Milan in one of the most unique ways
ever she reminds us of Selena Gomez but
the artist did an amazing job at showing
a modern Moulin sense Milan wears
traditional Chinese clothing it's fun to
see her in modern day clothes and
snuggle stems from deviantART
beautifully captured her dressed in
something a bit more modern we love that
you can still see the colors from the
iconic Mulan dress
Nina deluxe from deviantART turned Milan
into a high schooler and reimagined her
as a sporty but yet still girly
character a modern-day Mulan would
definitely be addicted to sports and she
better than anyone else in her school we
do think that each Disney princess has
an actual celebrity look-alike and in
our opinion mulan definitely looks like
jamie chung
we're pretty sure mulan would do just
fine in the modern world she'd probably
even teach us a life lesson or two belle
and you know we can't forget about one
of our favorite Disney Princesses ever
as a bookworm Belle definitely has a
sport in the modern day world we can
totally see her fit in of course there's
more to Belle than just her passion for
books and these artists beautifully
captured what Belle would look like
today
so talented Fernanda Suarez reimagined
Belle and honestly it's one of the best
illustrations we have ever seen
messy hair the book in her hand and the
denim jackets all maker looked totally
awesome
Lyle's from deviantART stressed Belle in
a hipster outfit added platform shoes
and gave her reading glasses is that
mustache on a stick
to him she looks adorable whisper wings
from deviantART is the beauty and the
beast' princess a casual look there's
nothing we love more than a Disney
Princess in teens Mina deluxe from
deviantART Twitter and modern high
school and shows that Belle can pretty
much rock any clothing style and Matt's
works reimagined her as an ordinary girl
with a Starbucks in her hand a book and
the other and an adorable satchel bag
Belle looks awesome with glasses
fusing other characters from Beauty and
the Beast would still exist in the
modern world we can't even imagine what
the Beast would actually look like
Pocahontas and Pocahontas is your
favorite Disney Princess you'll
absolutely love what we have to show you
the internet is full of talented people
and it seems like a lot of them are
Disney fans
Pocahontas teaches us to stand up for
what we believe in and it seems like
that the modern-day illustration showed
just that
Fernanda Suarez made the new-age
Pocahontas look fierce and ready to
stand her ground
we love the added jewelry Nina deluxe
again showed what Pocahontas would look
like in a high school setting but it's
completely different from what you'd
expect we have to say we're in love with
the rebellious and the same time chic
look of the high school Pocahontas
here's another illustration that shows
how important it is to be bold and
follow the beat of your own drum it
belongs to namely and we're totally
digging Pocahontas is casual look the
oversized shirt sweat him the cute boots
along with the accessories are
absolutely perfect and Tudor style we
can totally see a modern-day Pocahontas
sticking to her origin but being a
popular icon when it comes to speaking
about human rights in fact we know a
real-life celebrity who looks like a
perfect modern Pocahontas it's
everyone's favorite youtube star Lily
sing come to think of it we back
Pocahontas would have a youtube channel
to snow white snow white in the 7 door
flips the first full-length movie that
featured a Disney Princess and it's the
movie that made everyone fall in love no
it's look is totally iconic but these
artists managed to beautifully recreate
her in the modern world
Fernandez Juarez stuck with original
snow-white colors but turned her style
into something you would
easily see today we're in love with her
short hair however no bill on d1 from
deviantART reminded the original Disney
Princess in a completely new way and
we're totally faking it the pinup
version of Snow White is different but
it works
we love the dwarf tattoos on her body on
the other hand shiny Nico from
deviantART reimagined Snow White is your
typical high school girl let's just hope
she doesn't actually eat that Apple
here's another version for you big one
belongs to Christina Webb constructed
Snow White's original clothing but made
it slightly more modern we love seeing
Disney Princesses in casual clothes and
so why can't ice
illustration gives us jazz stats and of
course modern Disney Princesses have to
use modern technology here's the young
86's version which also features an iPad
we do think that out of all modern
versions we've shown you Katy Perry
could definitely rock the snow white
look which one of these was your
favorite let us know in the comments
jasmine
we've already shown you many versions of
Princess Jasmine in alternate universes
but the modern-day illustrations have to
be some of our favorites jasmine is
headstrong but what's sassy so we can
definitely see her fitting into today's
world she's teaching us that dreams do
come true and that you should never give
up hope Fernando suárez gave Jasmine a
totally modern look and Raja the pet
tiger got replaced by an orange cat
doesn't she look gorgeous
Rapunzel no more from deviantART stuck -
Jasmine's blue outfit but gave her
unique styles that we definitely see in
the modern world our favorite has to be
the blue maxi dress pan and art from
deviantART gave Jasmine a hijab and
stuck to the iconic blue style doesn't
she look amazing and Scott sketches
turned the aladdin princess into a
Shopaholic we all know she's a
fashionista by heart and it looks like
she can rock just about any look we said
it before but we really do love Disney
Princesses in jeans and zav draw our D
from deviantART gave us a pretty good
impression of what Jasmine would look
like in a casual outfit we love the
iconic jewelry and the blue blouse
Nicole shared singer would make the
perfect modern day Jasmine they both
look gorgeous they have beautiful voices
and they never give up we'd welcome
Jasmine into the real world any
Moana Moana has been one of the most
popular modern-day Disney Princesses her
whole look shows us a different side to
the original princesses we know and love
it's also her head strong personality
and her unique story that makes her
stand out from the rest
we love Moana and it turns out that
these illustrators love her too
Archibald art from tumblr gave us two
unique illustrations of a modern-day
Moana we're totally digging the
fashionable look on the first picture it
looks like the modern Moana replaced the
flowers in her hair for the flowers on
her cardigan but Archibald arts second
picture shows a lifelike princess and
it's amazing
Sophie smile from deviantART also did a
fantastic job reimagine Moana in denim
shorts and a cute top and here's another
illustration showing Moana in casual
clothing because we just can't get
enough she's gorgeous we're also very
impressed with taja a meses photo of two
of our favorite Beach girls if you ever
wanted to see Ariel and Moana together
you'll love this Bay looks totally
realistic and we'd love to actually see
them together in real life the real-life
version of Moana of course belongs to
the one and only owl EE crevo ho who's
not only fantastic but it's actually a
total coincidence she looks like her
Cinderella how could we possibly forget
about Cinderella one of the original
Disney Princesses her story is
absolutely magical and her look is
totally fabulous but would she survive
in the modern world these talented
artists sure thanks out Fernanda Suarez
beautifully reimagined her in a modern
setting and we're totally digging her
gorgeous hair is that a notebook with a
glass slipper milk tiered from Instagram
also illustrated Cinderella as I'm a
modern-day princess and gave her a brand
new outfit we loved the iconic blue
color but you can't deny that denim
always looks good on Disney
Tessa's Steve pica from deviantART gave
Cinderella a beautiful dress and
gorgeous high heels while art by Jody
from tumblr Illustrated her with an
actual bird Cinderella would definitely
be a fashionable girl in a cute dress
and she probably still loved animals as
always Disney Princesses in a casual
outfit still look the best and so does
Cinderella whisper wings from deviantART
did an amazing job at illustrating this
modern princess and it looks like she
ditched her old glass slipper and
replaced it with awesome pink heels we
do think that she does have an actual
celebrity look-alike in our opinion it's
January Jones what do you think with
Cinderella's character survived the
modern world or what you have to team up
with another Disney Princess who's your
favorite let us know in the comments
below that's it for 10 disney princesses
reimagined as modern-day women for more
videos like this one check out 10 disney
princesses reimagined as modern-day bad
girls see you in the next video
[Music]